CONGRESSMAN, ANDY BIGGS, THANK
YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
>>> ON THIS SHOW, WE HAVE LONG
EMPHASIZED THAT OPEN BORDERS
HAVE SERIOUS NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS.
JOINING US RETIRED CIA SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER, DANIEL
HOFFMANN.
FORMER MEMBER OF THE FBI JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCE, STEVE
ROGERS.
THE SHOOTING OF A CALIFORNIA
POLICE OFFICER BY AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT, KNOWN GANG
AFFILIATIONS, DOESN'T THAT
UNDERSCORE THERE ARE LEGIT MASS
SAFETY AND NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERNS AT RISK HERE, WHICH IS
WHY THERE NEEDS TO BE NOT JUST
BORDER SECURITY BUT A WALL?
>> IT CERTAINLY PROVES PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S POINT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN VERY
CONSISTENT.
HE IS MAKING DECISIONS BASED ON
NATIONAL SECURITY, TWO WORD NOT
IN THE VOCABULARY OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT SAYING, WE
ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO STOP THE INFLUX OF
WEAPONS AND DRUGS AND THOSE
THINGS THAT THREATEN NATIONAL
SECURITY.
LET'S KEEP ONE THING IN MIND.
HE WENT TO THE BORDER.
HE TALKED TO POLICE OFFICERS AND
BORDER AGENCIES.
MANAGEMENT BY WALKING AROUND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOES DOWN, GETS
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THOSE
CONFRONTED AND CHALLENGED BY
CRIMINALS.
HE MADE THE DECISION THAT'S WHAT
HAS TO BE DONE, THE WALL.
>> DAN HOFFMANN, GIVEN YOUR
BACKGROUND WITH THE CIA, TALK TO
US ABOUT THE SAFETY AND NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS THAT MAY BE AT
RISK WITHOUT A WALL AND WITHOUT
PROPER BORDER SECURITY.
>> I THINK THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT CONSTRUCTING A WALL AT
STRATEGIC LOCATIONS WITH
SURVEILLANCE AND A DEDICATED
BORDER PATROL CAN BE A LAST LINE
OF DEFENSE AGAINST TRANSNATIONAL
CRIMINALS AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
TRYSTS TO USE WHAT IS IN SOME
PLACES A VERY POROUS BORDER.
FROM MY EXPERIENCE AT THE CIA, I
THINK WE NEED TO GET OUT FRONT
OF THIS AND WORK WITH OUR
MEXICAN PARTNERS.
WE HAVE HAD SOME PRETTY GOOD
COLLABORATION WITH THEM AND HIT
THE CARTELS PRETTY HARD TO
REDUCE THE DRUG FLOW INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
SEPARATELY, WE NEED eVERIFY SO
ILLEGAL ALIENS CAN'T WORK HERE
AND A VISA TRACKING SYSTEM.
RUFFLE 40% OF ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE
OVERSTAYING THEIR VISAS.
AS A CITIZEN, I'M SH
AS A CITIZEN, I'M CHAGRINNED AT
THE BREAKDOWN OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM IS ABOUT $5
BILLION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE CAN'T
GET IT DONE AND DO A LITTLE
COMPROMISE.
>> MAYBE IT IS COMING DOWN TO
SEMANTICS, STEVE.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS A WALL.
SOME DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING, WELL,
A FENCE WOULD BE OKAY.
THAT'S JUST A SILLY SEMANTICAL
ARGUMENT.
>> DAN SAID SOMETHING VERY
INTERESTING THAT NOBODY WANTS TO
TALK B THE POTENTIAL OF
TERRORISTS CROSSING THAT BORDER.
I HAVE TO GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP A
LOT OF CREDIT ON HAVING VISION
AND FORETHOUGHT FROM PREVENTING
THAT FROM HAPPENING.
THAT'S WHY THE WALL IS
IMPORTANT.
>> I HEAR DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA, WHICH I REALIZE IS
REDUNDANT, SAY, YOU KNOW, YOU
BUILD A WALL 12-FEET TALL,
THEY'LL GET A 13-FOOT LADDER.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND SO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT?
>> I'M GOING TO INVOKE THE LATE
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER WHO SAID WE
NEED TO REDUCE THE RIVER OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION TO A
TRICKLE.
IS THE BORDER WALL A PANACEA?
IS IT GOING TO STOP ALL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION?
NO BUT IT IS GOING TO REDUCE IT
AND MAKE IT HARDER FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION TO TAKE PLACE.
THAT WILL DEINCENTIVIZE PEOPLE
FROM MAKING AN ARDUOUS JOURNEY
WHERE MANY OF THEM RISK AND
SOMETIMES LOSE THEIR LIVES.
DO WE KNOW OF CASES WHERE TRYSTS
DO WE KNOW OF CASES WHERE TRYS S
TERRORISTS HAVE COME ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> I REMEMBER WHEN THE LATE
SENATOR JOHN McCAIN WAS GRILLING
UNDERSECRETARY FRANCES TAYLOR
ABOUT TRANSNATIONAL CRIMINALS
CROSSING THE BORDER AND WHETHER
THERE WERE TERRORISTS THAT
CROSSED THAT BORDER?
>> HE DIDN'T DO A WHOLE LOT TO
CONVINCE ME THAT DHS WAS ABLE TO
DETECT WHETHER TERRORISTS HAD
CROSSED THE BORDER OR IF THEY
HAD AT SOME POINT IN THE PAST
DONE THAT.
TERRORISTS ARE LOOKING FOR THE
SOFT SPOTS AND THE
VULNERABILITIES TO EXPLOIT.
IF WE SEE A VULNERABILITY, BEST
TO SHUT IT DOWN BEFORE SOMEONE
EXPLOITS IT TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
WE DON'T WANT THOSE THREATS
VISITED ON OUR SHORES.
>> STEVE, I SEE YOU NODDING YOUR
HEAD AT THAT.
>> DAN HAS THIS NAILED DOWN.
MS-13 GANG MEMBERS ARE
TERRORISTS AND THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR AVENUES TO GET INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
WITHOUT A WALL, IT MAKES IT MUCH
EASIER.
YOU COULD GET A STRONG DOOR.
THERE WILL BE A BURGLAR THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO GET IN THAT DOOR
BUT IT BUYS TIME FOR THE POLICE
TO RESPOND AND DO WHAT THEY CAN
DO.
>> NOT EVERYBODY CAN BRING A
LADDER TO THE WALL.